ain't nothing better than waiting except
for bloody everything else
hey everyone i'm jordan and i'm joined
by max hello
and we're here to talk about apex
legends season six boosted specifically
the new legend
rampart who we've both been playing as
over the past couple of days we're going
to be talking about her abilities best
strategies combinations and
whatnot but let's start with her
abilities first specifically her
tactical ability amped cover which is
basically a rework of titanfall
2's amped wall so it is a little bit
different from the a wall and titanfall
there is a buildup time that you have to
wait for
for it to be fully activated the wall
when first deployed it takes about
i don't know a couple seconds for the
bottom portion to reinforce itself and
then the top portion to actually build
the bottom portion has 400 hp the top
portion is 200 that 200 portion is the
amped portion which makes outgoing
bullets do more damage and incoming
bullets blocked
this porsche can also be clambered over
so just like gibby's shield it's a
barrier that can be walked through
yeah rampart best specializes in taking
advantage of chokepoint setting up her
walls to stop
other squads from getting any closer to
her squad the problem is as you said it
takes a while for her walls to actually
be
built up so she's not a character that
you kind of want to
run at a fight and start setting up
walls you kind of want to find a really
good position
specifically a choke point and start
throwing up her defenses to take
advantage of the situation so that when
an enemy squad comes to you
you're already set up and ready to go
yeah it is definitely a preemptive
tactical because
of the delicacy of its building portion
because
any one shot will take it out these are
also collapsible really quickly so
if you need to replace one you can do so
fairly quickly after it's deployed
and on top of that if you planned ahead
really well you can have up to five
walls at a time so you can really build
up your defenses
very well if you want to now there's a
couple rules to this
wall you can't have two in a row uh if
you shoot through the second one
the front one will be destroyed so
there's no choosing multi-amped walls
in the building portion it does take one
damage to destroy it but that's
any one damage of any amount if you put
it in front of an arc star or a frag
that's considered burst damage so that
will block that hit for you which is
pretty nifty in a situation where you
can't get out of the way
because it also is a solid object you
can use to climb higher than normal
and you can also use it to block doors
which is very very useful against choke
situations or pinch situations now
rampart is a little bit unique
in her passive ability modded loader she
is the first
character who's naturally better with a
certain type of weapon in comparison to
the other characters who have come to
apex legends before
other characters can benefit from having
certain weapons like octane is naturally
good with
close range weapons because he's all
about approaching the enemy squad as
quickly as possible
but rampart's passive specifically makes
her really good with lmgs it
increases the overall magazine size for
lmgs and
also allows her to reload lmgs a lot
faster
so yeah this includes the spitfire the l
star and the devotion
those three weapons are gonna be in
rampart's wheelhouse
so if you come across a purple mag with
a spitfire or a devotion
you're just a literal bullet hoes with
rampart you have
so many bullets this makes her really
good at just spraying and praying
and really putting out that damage
against any defenses
i would say it makes her really really
good with the
l-star which doesn't have a traditional
clip but just takes longer to
overheat and cools down a lot faster
when you first drop into the match
rampart has a natural advantage with
those guns because it's
it's technically like having a level one
mag immediately off the bat with those
lmgs
and even on the off chance that you
don't find an
lmg rampart just has one naturally on
her
in her ultimate ability in place the
minigun sheila
which allows her to place up to three of
her sheila turrets just anywhere on the
battlefield for her
or her squad mates to use and it is a
incredibly deadly firearm so yeah sheila
is an absolute monster the highest dps
in the game actually
she eats through anything that's in
front of her doors
enemies they get absolutely destroyed
but there is a caveat to this ultimate
uh it is the highest dps in the game but
takes a long time to set her up
takes a long time to start firing and it
takes a long time to get the accuracy
down to a t
the system in firing sheila makes it so
that you don't want to fire in bursts
you want to just keep holding on the
trigger because the spray
will widen out if you let go so you want
to keep the trigger on and keep the
firing straight so you can get the most
accuracy for your shots
you can also zoom in with the flip side
to get a closer look at your terrified
enemies
so that's why you usually want to
fortify your position first by using amp
to cover in front of sheila so that you
can get those damaging shots and you can
protect yourself a little bit before the
wall goes down you start getting shot
yourself
yeah just like your tactical ability
ramparts ultimate ability is something
that you kind of want to set up ahead of
time because you
want everything set up so that you can
just destroy the enemy squad as soon as
they come into view
basically everything about rampart is
being prepared for the fight ahead
on the flip side though she's against an
enemy legend who's really good at
rushing an
enemy's encampment or just destroying an
enemy's encampment she has
very little to counter the counter
against her
like crypto is all about destroying
the setup of other legends like caustic
and watson basically
are demolished by crypto like you said
crypto is a hard counter to rampart
while it doesn't destroy
everything that she owns the amp walls
are gone the bottom portions are damaged
and sheila is actually disabled for a
while so you'll really want to prepare
yourself if kryptos emp
is incoming and also a counter to
rampart is rampart herself her minigun
destroys walls very very quickly so it's
basically a race to see who can set up
sheila fastest and take out your
defenses first
but it's not all bad rampart can hold
her own especially if she has
really good teammates to accentuate the
abilities that she currently has for
example if you run
rampart with caustic and watson you can
put up a
really solid defense use rampart's
tactical ability to shield the
fence pylons of watson's tactical
ability or even place
caustic traps in the midst of all the
defenses that they're putting up to stop
enemy squads from reaching you
in time while rampart and watson put up
their defenses
you can make a really strong defensive
shell if you run rampart with the other
defender characters
so yeah that's rampart those are her
abilities those are her best combos her
best counters but
how is she actually in the game how does
she work max you've been playing as
rampart for a few days now
is she for you is she your new mane
she's not for me
i definitely see people of this play
style that will definitely benefit from
her but yeah personally not my playstyle
i like a more aggressive play style like
wraith
and her preemptive play style with
defense is not really my cup of tea but
i feel like people who really like to
set up a strong defense on the high
ground
will really benefit with their play
style but that's what we think about
rampart season six is new legend what do
you think of the new character do you
like her do you hate her are there any
hidden strats that you want to share
with everyone else
just leave your suggestions in the
comment section below and be sure to
stay tuned to gamespot we'll be covering
apex legends news and big announcements
you